>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT," IF YOU HAVE BEEN
WATCHING TELEVISION RECENTLY YOU
PROBABLY HEARD THE BAD NEWS.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
OVER.
TOAST, COOKED, DONE FOR GOOD,
AND ALONG WITH IT ANY HOPE OF
THE MIDDLE-CLASS REVOLUTION THAT
63 MILLION AMERICANS VOTED FOR
TWO YEARS AGO, THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN CAUGHT COMMITTING FELONIES,
HERE IS WHETHER LEGAL EXPERTS
WITHOUT LAW DEGREES ARE SAYING
ON TELEVISION.
>> IF PRECEDENT MEANS ANYTHING
IN THE TRUMP ERA, DONALD TRUMP,
MUST BE, WILL BE IMPEACHED
BECAUSE OF THE CRIMES THAT
PROSECUTORS SAY HE COMMITTED IN
THE MICHAEL COHEN CASE.
>> BOTH PARTIES NEED TO GET ON
BOARD TO PASS ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
>> YOU HAVE CONSPIRACY, YOU HAVE
OBSTRUCTION COMING UP CAMPAIGN
FINANCE.
>> IF THE DEMOCRATS DO NOT
PURSUE THIS VIGOROUSLY, THEY
WILL BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
ABDICATING THEIR RESPONSIBILITY.
>> IT GOES TO THE MUELLER
QUESTION.
THE ETHICAL QUESTION.
A DEMOCRACY IS AT STAKE.
TO SPEAK OF THIS CRIMINAL MUST
BE BROUGHT UP BY THE UNITED STAT
BE BROUGHT UP BY THE UNITED STAS
BE BROUGHT UP BY THE UNITED STAF
BE BROUGHT UP BY THE UNITED STAR
IMPEACHMENT.
>> Tucker: GOING TO SHOW YOU
THE DON THEM ON TAPE, BUT TO SUM
UP THEY ARE TELLING US THAT
WE ARE STARING DOWN THE BARREL
OF A CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
AND THEN CRISIS STEMS FROM WHAT
MSNBC DESCRIBES AS "THE CRIMES
PROSECUTOR SAVED THE PRESIDENT
COMMITTED IN THE MICHAEL COHEN
CASE."
WHICH CRIMES WERE THOSE?
WE HAVE THE ANSWER, THE RELEVANT
DETAILS WERE SPELLED OUT IN A
PIECE THAT RAN OVER THE WEEKEND
TO "THE NEW YORK TIMES" UNDER
THIS HEADLINE.
PROSECUTORS SAY THAT TO TRUMP
DIRECTED A LEAGUE ILLEGAL
PAYMENTS DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
THE GIST IS THIS, TRUMP’S FORMER
LAWYER MICHAEL COHEN HAS TOLD
FORMER PROSECUTORS THAT HE
FACILITATED PAYMENTS TO TWO
WOMEN WHO SAID THAT THEY HAD
AFFAIRS WITH DONALD TRUMP.
AND THEN, ACTUALLY, THAT IS IT.
THAT IS THE ENTIRE STORY RIGHT
THERE.
PAYING THE TWO WOMEN, SAYING FOR
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS WAS A
SERIOUS CRIME, A CRIME WORTHY OF
IMPEACHMENT, IF NOT INDICTMENT.
OKAY, BUT YOU MIGHT BE WONDERING
HOW EXACTLY THAT IS CRIMINAL.
WE WILL STIPULATE THAT
EVERYTHING THAT MICHAEL COHEN
HAS TOLD THE FEDS IS ABSOLUTELY
TRUE.
ASSUMING ANNA’S FEE IS NOT A
WISE IDEA WITH MICHAEL COHEN,
BUT FOR THE SAKE OF ARGUMENT
LET’S DO IT IN THIS CASE.
EVERYTHING HE SAYS IS TRUE, WHY
IS WHAT HE IS LEGEND A CRIMINAL
OFFENSE?
REMEMBER THE FACTS OF THE STORY
ARE UNDISPUTED, TWO WOMEN
APPROACH DONALD TRUMP AND
THREATENED TO RUIN HIS CAREER
AND RUIN HIS FAMILY IF HE DOES
NOT GIVE THEM MONEY.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A CLASSIC CASE
OF EXTORTION.
BUT FOR WHATEVER REASON TRUMP
CAVES TO IT AND DIRECTS MICHAEL
COHEN TO PAY THE RANSOM.
NOW MORE THAN TWO YEARS LATER
TRUMP IS A FELON FOR DOING THIS.
IT DOES NOT SEEM TO MAKE ANY
SENSE.
OH, BUT YOU ARE NOT A FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR ON A POLITICAL
MACHINE.
IF YOU WERE A FEDERAL PROSECUTOR
ON A POLITICAL MACHINE, YOU
WOULD CONSTRUE THOSE EXTORTION
PAYMENTS AS CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS.
YOU DO THIS EVEN THOUGH THE
MONEY IN QUESTION DID NOT COME
FROM OR GO TO DONALD TRUMP’S
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
THEY KNEW WOULD CLAIM THAT TRUMP
AND MICHAEL COYNE VIOLATED
CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAW BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT PUBLICLY DISCLOSE
THOSE PAYMENTS.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT DISCLOSING
THEM WOULD NULLIFY THE REASON
FOR MAKING THEM IN THE FIRST
PLACE WHICH WAS TO KEEP THE
WHOLE THING SECRET.
THAT IS THE ARGUMENT YOU WOULD
MAKE BOTH IN FEDERAL COURT AND
FOR YOUR PROXIES ON CABLE
TELEVISION.
IT IS INSULTINGLY STUPID.
BUT BECAUSE EVERYONE IN POWER
HATES THE TARGET OF YOUR
INVESTIGATION, NOBODY WOULD
QUESTION YOU.
AND THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW.
NOW BY THIS REASONING, ANY MONEY
OF POLITICAL CANDIDATE SPENDS TO
MAINTAIN OR PROTECT THEIR IMAGE
DURING OFFICE NOW QUALIFIES AS A
REGULATED CAMPAIGN DONATION AND
HAS TO BE DISCLOSED.
THAT WOULD BE INCLUDED WITH AN
INFINITE NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS,
BUYING TOOTHPASTE AND GETTING A
HAIRCUT.
IT WOULD DEFINITELY INCLUDE THE
TAXPAYER FINANCE SLUSH FUND THAT
CONGRESS HAS SET ASIDE TO PAY
OFF ITS OWN SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CLAIMS.
YES, THOSE NOW QUALIFY AS
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS.
THEY MUST BE PUBLICLY DISCLOSED.
EXCEPT, OF COURSE THEY ARE NOT
PUBLICLY DISCLOSED AND THEY
NEVER WILL BE.
WHY IS THAT?
THAT MAY BE A QUESTION FOR
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS INCLUDING,
NOW THAT WE THINK ABOUT IT, ADAM
NOW THAT WE THINK ABOUT IT, ADAMSCHIFF FROM BURBANK, CALIFORNIA.
SCHIFF FROM BURBANK, CALIFORNIA.
THE INCOMING CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE OF INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
WHAT DOES HE HAVE TO SAY ABOUT
CONGRESS NOT DISCLOSING THE VERY
SAME PAYMENTS THAT DEMOCRATS SAY
SAME PAYMENTS THAT DEMOCRATS SAT
SAME PAYMENTS THAT DEMOCRATS SAU
SAME PAYMENTS THAT DEMOCRATS SAP
SAME PAYMENTS THAT DEMOCRATS SAS
SAME PAYMENTS THAT DEMOCRATS SAO
SAME PAYMENTS THAT DEMOCRATS SAL
SAME PAYMENTS THAT DEMOCRATS SAD
SAME PAYMENTS THAT DEMOCRATS SAB
SAME PAYMENTS THAT DEMOCRATS SAE
IMPEACHED FOR NOT DISCLOSING.
LET’S ASK HIM.
>> THERE IS A REAL PROSPECT THAT
ON THE DAY DONALD TRUMP LEAVES
OFFICE, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
MAY INDICT HIM.
THAT HE MAY BE THE FIRST
PRESIDENT IN QUITE SOME TIME TO
FACE THE PROSPECT OF JAIL TIME.
>> TRUMP KNOWS THAT HE IS FACING
SOME PRETTY STRONG CRIMINAL
LIABILITY WHEN HE LEAVES OFFICE,
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
AND EVEN IF A SITTING PRESIDENT
CANNOT BE INDICTED, HE HAS TO
KNOW THAT HIS FUTURE LOOKS LIKE
IT IS BEHIND BARS UNLESS HE CUTS
SOME SORT OF DEAL WITH THE
PROSECUTORS.
>> Tucker: SO TO TRANSLATE,
TRUMP IS A CRIMINAL, HE IS GOING
TO JAIL.
FOR COMMITTING THE SMALLER
VERSION OF THE MADE UP A CRIME
THAT WE IN CONGRESS HAVE
COMMITTED FOR YEARS AND FORCE
YOU TO PAY FOR.
WE ARE NEVER APOLOGIZING FOR
THAT.
BECAUSE WE DO NOT HAVE TO, AND